in my 20s and I've dated people and for
some reason that is uh very crazy and
interesting to people I don't think it's
that interesting Pete Davidson has dated
some of the most famous women in
Hollywood but when it comes to the
Public's fascination with his love life
he says he doesn't get it I've been
fortunate enough to have some great
relationships the comedian was a guest
on Thursday's episode of the real ones
with John Bernthal podcast where he
opened up about the Public's fascination
with his love life
12 years I've dated like 10 people I
don't really think that's that crazy but
to some people it seems very interesting
and uh that became sort of like all
anyone would talk about of course Pete
has been in several high-profile
relationships in 2018 he popped the
question to Ariana Grande the singer
famously gave him a post-split shout out
in her 2019 track thank you next
since then he's been linked to Kate
Beckinsale Margaret quali Kaya Gerber
Phoebe Denver and of course Kim
Kardashian
he's just super genuine
Pete even had Kim's famous family seal
of approval I love the chemistry that
Kim and him have together it's really
sweet I thought she said the chemistry
was like okay chemistry chemistry well
that chemistry fizzled out after nine
months together they called it quits
last year and he dated Emily radakowski
for a hot SEC he seems super Charming
he's vulnerable he's lovely now he's
dating his bodies bodies bodies co-star
Chase Suey wonders
the two have been linked for several
months and back in January A source told
E.T they like each other a lot and while
his list of past Flames is like a who's
who of Hollywood Pete says it's
confusing that people are so invested in
his relationships not like flexing you
know what I mean and these people that
I've dated like I met them at work like
I I wasn't in anyone's DMS no one was in
mine like I worked at one of the five
Hollywood epicenters of meat people
where you meet people the guy's got a
point he couldn't have even slid into
someone's DMS if he wanted to he just
returned to the gram this week after
deleting his account last year following
a public Feud with his then-girlfriend
Kim's ex Kanye West
God sent me from that crash just so I
could be Pete Davidson's ass and while
Pete says he's cool with his friends
making jokes about his love life he says
he felt like a loser when they made fun
of him on SNL when it's your own show
and you know like I'll be sitting in the
back watching the cold open and you know
the cold open is topical political humor
or whatever whatever's in the culture
and and then making fun of you
and then you gotta walk out and do a
sketch next and hit your mark and the
show just made fun of you so why are
they gonna laugh at you like they just
dogged you in front of everyone hello
millions of people only watching to see
if I bring up Kanye but for Pete the
future looks bright he left the sketch
comedy show in 2022 and his new series
bobkus is set to Premiere May 4th on
peacock
foreign